[Music]
oh
honey i am tired i am going to bed
good night uh
well is everything okay
well it's uh it's just that i was uh
hoping that uh well that we could
and uh i i want to make this clear uh
i want to be uh straightforward i want
to uh
have a okay uh luther are you available
to translate yes ma'am
i really was hoping we could spend some
time together when is the last time we
had sex woman re-election night what
does a brother not named bill clinton
have to do to get some
in this house well you have been very
busy
lately you know what
if i could can we get your translator oh
yes certainly uh
katendra
yeah honey could you please translate
well you have been very busy
lately sure my
one of your limousines that you can jump
in and out of whenever you feel like
i don't see you all day then you want a
booty car
i need an emotional connection
thought this was uh romantic i'm trying
[ __ ] can't you see
i'm playing the romantic music i got the
pinot in the glasses what more do you
want from me an engraved invitation from
my nuts
maybe we should make a date what am i
supposed to do
jump out of my clothes every time little
bear stands at attention
you ain't my commander-in-chief mother
and my vagina ain't some cave in the
middle east
you can fly your heat-seeking missile
into whenever you feel
like it well huh
i didn't mean to call you but i-i had
meetings all day long i'm dealing with
these
mother republicans hearing no no no
all day long then i come home and you're
gonna let me get my jam on up in here
well you know i have had a busy day too
you act like i ain't got nothing else to
do i got these obese [ __ ] on my
ass 24
7. what's more important you getting
your wig dipped
or some eight-year-old fat ass
collapsing his bunk bed
okay you seem to be forgetting job
number one
you are my secretary of [ __ ] get
to work you
yeah we'll uh we'll take it from here
absolutely yes sir
oh this feels good uh mom
dad i know you already said that i can't
go but can i please go to the party
tonight
malia use your translator
if you don't let me go to this party i
will get a tattoo
on my face have fun
you